[Music]
jackson is in tampa florida hi jackson
how are you
hey i'm doing well how are you better
than i deserve what's up
hey got a question regarding the
mortgage i know you guys talk about um i
have no debt and
i know you talked about putting 15
percent towards investments and then the
rest going towards your mortgage
my wife and i my wife and i are
incredibly risk tolerant
lost about 50 000 in our mutual funds
over the past month
and still just sold my car invested that
money straight into the stock market
because they're on sale
um so i know well i think that the math
says investments you're obviously a very
successful man so i'm not going to argue
with you but i'd like to genuinely know
why why do you go with that approach
versus the investments if you're risk
tolerant
well
risk tolerance has to do with what your
emotions will allow you to do without
going into freakout mode
sure okay
um and so
someone who has a very low risk
tolerance
can become a poor investor
based on the fact that their low risk
tolerance causes them to not take enough
risk agreed
someone who has too high a risk
tolerance can cause them to be a poor
investor
because they take risky investments that
end up losing more than they make
because they live out on the edge
yeah i'm i'm like i'm 99 mutual funds
i'm one percent in football helmets so
like i'm in
i like it oh this is soaked we have a
new measure of things this is awesome
born on the air today i love it the fact
that
jackson you get the award regard you
could go do whatever you want after that
so no i'm kidding all right so uh
um
yeah but my point is okay so i grew up
in the real estate business and one of
the things you do in the real estate
business is they take your risk meter
and they break it with a hammer real
estate people have complete risk
tolerance we're idiots we're idiots we
don't even know there's risk
okay and that's what caused me to go
broke
because i was not measuring risk so
here's the here's what ends up happening
debt
equals risk more debt equals more risk
less debt equals less risk
uh it adds risk to the portfolio you're
saying i can emotionally tolerate that
that's one discussion another discussion
though is what is the
fastest route to wealth
regardless of risk tolerance
okay
what's the fastest route to wealth and
and you know and within that then okay
we've got to discuss can i stomach that
with my risk tolerance do i have enough
risk tolerance to go
that route the fastest surest
route to wealth not just
and most likely so
i would go back to something like
the 10 167 millionaires we studied
and the number of them that said because
i had a high risk tolerance i kept a
mortgage the whole time and i invested
all the money
and uh today i have a million dollars in
mutual funds
i have two million dollars in mutual
funds and i owe
600 000 on my house
the number of them that said that was
less than 10 percent
90 plus percent
said i got my house paid off and i
dumped everything in mutual funds in my
401 case
okay so
the practical facts are
the the normative way the most likely
way the highest probability way
according to the data to bill wealth is
to invest into mutual funds and to get
the house paid off um
instead of because otherwise you would
say you would say all right i'm going to
borrow as much as i can borrow on the
house all the time and every so often
i'm going to refinance it and throw all
of that money with the cash out into the
and stay mortgaged up to my eyeballs
yeah if the concept worked you would do
that but the problem with that is is
that it affects other things in the
unseen and that is is that the borrower
slave to the lender you make different
decisions in your life when you don't
have a house payment
about your career yeah
it puts different stresses on your
relationships
it you treat you know your children
different there's different levels of
health issues when there's no debt
versus if there's debt regardless of
risk tolerance all of those things end
up applying out there in the real world
yeah i keep going back to the car you
said you're you sold your car to an
investor
do you need it so no
no i don't that actually that was just
uh i sold i i was able to sell my car it
was a honda a 2008 honda fit i sold it
for 300 more than i bought it for uh
five years ago and so i bought an
electric bike and i take that to work
i'm only three miles from work um the
problem is i do live in you know florida
so i'm gonna start sweating here soon um
but no the that just i just my life and
i felt like we've got our 2015 minivan
and like we can be a one car family okay
um okay yeah so that was more well i
guess i'm just i'm having a little bit
of trouble wrapping my mind around the
math of it but maybe i need to let that
i don't think it no here's the okay the
math here's how the math works all right
in
graduate level
studies
in finance
or maybe even in a good school in the
senior year level
um we are taught to christina and i were
taught to
analyze two different mutual funds
okay an aggressive growth stock mutual
fund has a measure of risk called a beta
the higher the beta the higher the risk
the higher the peaks and valleys if you
chart it
the more volatile it is okay
high beta more risk okay
low beta less risk and so you take an
aggressive growth with a bay a high beta
and uh maybe a maybe a 2.5 beta or
something like that and then you take a
growth in income that might have a 0.8
beta
less than one
beta a one beta is the s p 500 what the
market does just to give you an example
okay so here's how the math works if
you're if you in order to compare those
two they have different volatility so
comparing them apples to apples is naive
you see what i'm saying
sure so you've the way you
mathematically adjust for it is there's
an inverse formula where the beta is
flipped on its head with in an inverse
fraction so that the beta reduces the
higher beta reduces the return
of the of the risky investment and the
lower beta
raises the return of the lower
investment so that after adjusted for
risk mathematically you can compare
these apples to apples does that make
any sense
it does i knew you were smarter than i
was and so yeah that that well it's just
it's just what i was taught academically
it's not i'm not yet
but so so the thing is what what has
never happened though we're taught that
in the financial world christina but
we're not taught
to do that with debt
and so we compare
a house with a mortgage equally to a
house without a mortgage
or an investment a property with a
mortgage equally to an investment
property without a mortgage and we do
not apply the increased risk
a beta
to the math formula
and so our that's what i mean by real
estate people the risk meter is broken
they don't analyze for risk and we don't
re and we don't mathematically adjust
for risk and so when we add the beta
idea or concept to your question it says
you are taking more risks so we should
put a higher beta on your plan a lower
beta on my plan and when we risk adjust
mathematically
our plans are going to be fairly equal
okay
that's helpful i really appreciate it
cool i don't know if that made any sense
or not something like a barrel fish
hooks but it is it is the truth that's
the academic way of approaching it the
spiritual way of approaching it is the
borrower is slave to the lender 100 of
the references in the bible to debt say
debt is stupid it's not a sin
you're a slave you're a fool you're
impulsive it always says that so if the
bible says and i'm a christian if the
bible says negative things about that it
doesn't say it's a sin doesn't say i'm
going to hell if i get a mastercard it's
not a salvation issue but but if
spiritually my heavenly father is saying
in his handbook there's nothing good
about debt then i have to read that and
believe it if i'm a person of faith
absolutely and then i can also go over
here and use my brain and use a beta and
either way i come to the same conclusion
yep that's such a great way of meshing
those two things together
yeah it's uh
but but the you know i actually um
was speaking to a graduate level group
at uh vandy one time and walked them
through that on the math idea and
they're like looking at me like i've
never heard that before
it's because nobody teaches it nobody
talks about debt equals risk so you need
to factor a beta into it a measure of
risk mathematically into it and when you
put in a measure of risk mathematically
into it it takes away the advantages of
debt and guess what we all know that
because when you're debt free you build
wealth faster so duh
you know that's kind of the way this
whole thing works it's an interesting
discussion i appreciate his question
that's great